oh
Dang
Hey What's up guys welcome back to the shop i'm here again with nate Today we're gonna be showing you how to take common parts
From The hardware store and Build an Air-powered T-Shirt cannon Let's Jump Right in
Nate is our newest and finest Addition to the team i brought Him on Board Because he's Helped me with a lot of cool projects
In the past?
Like The Giant squirt gun that We did That Was 4 Feet Tall 7 Feet wide he also Helped with decorating These T-Shirt cannons and
we did for Cvx live
Shooting T-Shirts Out Into the audience he also worked with Devin Graham on his Mario Kart in real life video where he built red turtle
Shells and Turned them into
Remote-control Racers That Go Up to 60 miles an hour and he might show you how to do that in a future video
Now the materials for This project are Very Simple you Just Run down to your local hardware store and pick Up some Abs fittings we
Have a Two-Foot length of 3-Inch Abs a Two-Foot length of
a 2 foot length of 2 inchAbs
Adapter From three inch to two inch we have 2
Three inch couplings and a three inch to one and a Half inch Adapter if You take a close look at These Adapters you can
See they've got a beveled edge on the inside but if you flip them over That's where the Tubes slide in and make a Tight
fit That's Just gonna make It look a Little more aesthetically Pleasing
Now in Addition to the Abs Fittings we're also gonna Bring in some PvC That's gonna Work the valve and
Give us a Place to pressurize it with bike Pump these are the parts That you're gonna Need the first adapter we're using is this
One and a Half inch to
3/4 inch slip Two Threaded Adapter That's gonna Fit into the Abs and from that all The rest of the parts are Threaded we're using
Six 3/4 inch Threaded Closed Nipples a 3/4 inch coupling to three-quarter inch 90 degree elbows a
3/4 inch tee and end cap and a 3/4 inch ball valve
Purpose of the end cap is to let us pressurize the system and if you want
To use a bike Pump you can Just use schrader valve Which we Picked up at the auto parts store
Or you can use a pneumatic quick connect Adapter so you can Fill It with an air hose
So now that we've got all our Pieces
Collected and Put Together There's two Things We Need to do first of all We Need to cut our Tubes to size and then we're
gonna glue most of these Pieces Together using Black Abs cement and some Green Abs 2 Pvc glue
Quick update Guys we made our cuts and Here's where we're at the 3-Inch Tube is Now 16 inches long
The Smaller Tube Is 2 Inches short and That's going to give a Little Room for our proto cutty plug to bounce Around inside
We also assembled all of The
Pvc parts We've Painted This Part of a Handle Yellow and The rest of its can Be painted all Black Just to make it look
Good
When you're painting PVC you want to make sure that you first do a light Dust coat Over the Whole surface
That Will Let The Next Layers of Paint Bond to the plastic Really well
otherwise It Has a Tendency to beat Up and not be a smooth coating
Now while nate is working on painting The PVC components Black I'm gonna be working on making a Proto Putty plug with this one-inch piece
of scrap That we Cut off the three inch tubing
Essentially we're Just gonna pack This Thing Full of proto putty make sure it's smooth on the top of the bottom and that Should Work
Perfectly for our prototype Lug
We Got The Handle all painted and the proto putty is setting That's going to be curing for there five or ten minutes and while
It is we're going to move on to assembling The body of the cannon?
Now to assemble the body of the cannon we're going to do it in three different parts we're gonna take the larger Tube and stick
It right Down inside of a Coupling first and glue That Together we're gonna take the smaller Tube and the smaller coupling we're gonna make
sure that the Beveled side is Faced down on the table and then we're gonna glue the tube it down inside the center of That
Pushing It All The Way down flat Now we're going to take the smaller coupling we're gonna set It down the table so the beveled
Side Is facing Up we're gonna take our 3-Inch coupling glue it up and we're gonna press it down until everything Goes completely Flat
Against the bottom before we Go any Further Let's take the smaller Tube and Rub It Around in circles on a piece of Sandpaper
Help Smooth Down That Edge and make a Little Bit Better Seal When the proto putty Makes Contact
And of Course This we're Just going Abs to Abs we're Just using the black Abs glue for this
Perfect okay
All these Pieces Went Together Beautifully and Now we've Got the inside Tube the outside team we're going to take the inside one we're going
to place it Facedown
Gonna Take The outside one glue it up and we're going to come straight down over top and press that Down?
So it's nice and. Flush on the bottom as well
Our protocol Puck is completely took This Thing Out of The Abs ring
Dusted It with a Little Bit of Baby powder and then Wiped It all down with a Paper towel to get a Nice clean and
Smooth Now the side that Was sitting down on the countertop is the
Smoothest Edge we want to take that we want to put It down inside of the three-inch Abs tubing and Push it all The Way
Down so It makes Contact with a Two inch Tube inside
That's going to block off The 2 inch Tube inside and allow uS to pressurize the system so now the only Things left to do
Are glue on the back Attach the handle and decorate it
Moment of truth 1 2 3 commit
boom There it is
so here we Have it Guys our t-Shirt cannon is Fully assembled Fully decorated and Pretty Much Ready for pressure testing and This is the
Basic Idea of How it works
You hook Up something Like an Air hose or a bike Pump to this valve here and as long as This valve is Closed it
Will Push the air up inside this chamber Now the proto putty plug will shift Upwards
Block The Tube on the inside and the rest of the air Wall
Shimmy Around The Plug and fill Up This large chamber on the inside when that pressurized up to 60 to 80
Psi it's held in place until you release This valve Because the instant this valve gets Turned open Any air behind the proto putty plug
Rushes Out Forcing The plug to slam down to the bottom and all the remaining air to shove Out the center of The tube this
Happens Very Very quickly and it's Very Very powerful now if you want to go the extra mile with Your decorations you can do something
Like What nate did putting a Crown on this one Make This Crown i laid the pattern over some Aluminum Foil tape and cut it
Out with an exacto knife Which i think is crazy Because Who'd cut that Out with an exacto knife It Does look Pretty Good though
You Gotta Admit so this point our t-Shirt cans are Ready for
pressurizing and you can Get Really Fancy With How you fold Your shirts or You could Just Shove them down the barrel you know pack
Them down tight with a stick and then release The Handle and They're gonna Fly anywhere Between 40 to 60 psi
These Things are gonna Work really Really Well
Quick shout-Out to my friend Been with Nighthawk and light for being The inspiration behind this project with His
Coaxial potato Cannon Of Which i put a Link down in the description
so before we wrap Up let's take These Things outside and show you what they can do
Alright so this is what It looks like set to 20 psi
Woohoo that good 10 to 15 feet and this is What It looks like at 60 oh?
Dang That Was awesome it's on the roof it's on the roof
There you go
Wow we Caught it Nice Positioning
So there you have it Guys That's how to take common parts From The hardware store and Turn them into a fully
Functional Air Powered T-Shirt cannon You can use them to shoot T-Shirts
Nerf Darts or anything Else That You can fit down the barrel hey thanks for Joining Us for this project if We look for the
Next One talk to you then oh?
Dude that Flies 80 feet 80 Feet
Might Still be in your Yard Going Down over Here
See you there no i don't see you back there i like that shirt
And You trust your TV a lot more Than i trust mine
something That's interesting about This Teflon tape is that if you pull it Sideways and
Stretch Crazy Amounts
One interesting side note is if you take One of The little Nerf Darts They fit down the barrel a Little Bit to perfectly
Dang House far
Hey Guys i want to Jump back in for Just a Second. To invite you
To come follow me on instagram i've Got a Very active page where i post daily
Pictures and Stories of Behind the scenes and Every day is an adventure
Just Take five Seconds Right Now to click the link in the description to come follow me on instagram at the King of Random?
I'll see you there